>>Male presenter: Hello, everybody. Thanks
for coming to Digital Arts@Google, the artist
lecture series for the second exhibition.
Today, we have a great speaker line-up for
you: Eduardo Kac, Marina Zurkow, Sandra Cordero
and our very own Andrew Senior. So, the Digital
Arts@Google Exhibition Series was started
by Josh Mittlemen, when he was thinking about
Google's mission, which is to organize the
world's information and make it accessible.
And being here in New York City, and especially
in Chelsea, in the arts district, he thought,
"Well, art is a great way to access or understand
information and so Google should be involved
in art and so he found Nina Colosi and invited
her to curate a series of art shows here to
further that and to also foster a collaboration
between artists and engineers. And the, and
this is the third lecture series and they'll
be another one. The next show opens, let's
see what, Nina, remind me what. Next Thursday
is the opening for the next show here in Chelsea
Market. So, tonight we have first
[pause]
speaking first will be Eduardo Kac, a pioneer
of telecommunications art started in the pre-Web
80s and then emerged in the early 90s with
his radical works combining telerobotics and
living organisms. His visionary integration
of robotics, biology and networking explores
the fluidity of subject positions in the post-Digital
world. His work deals with the mythopoetics
of online experience, cultural impact of biotechnology,
conditions of memory in the digital age, distributive
collective agency and the creation of life
itself. At the dawn of the 21st Century, Kac
opened a new direction with contemporary art
with his transgenic art. First, the groundbreaking
Genesis in 1999, which included the artists
gene that he invented and then with his fluorescent
rabbit called Alba. Mr. Kac.
>>Kac: Thank you.
[applause]
Thank you very much. So, in reality, and this
is an interesting coincidence, those are exactly
the works I'm gonna be presenting: the work
that goes with memory, the Genesis and GFP
Bunny. So, we have 20 minutes and I will then
begin in 1997, with this artwork called Time
Capsule. And it's an important work in my
introductory because, for me, it represents
a turning point. It's a moment in which I
begin to expand my digital work in the realm
of biology. The term "bioart" I coined back
in '97 specifically to signify, to connote,
this passage. And the Time Capsule has, as
referenced, these seven sepia tone photographs
that my grandmother brought from Poland before
'39, when she escaped the war. And it is in
front of the seven sepia tone photographs
that represent members of her family who did
not survive the war, that I implanted a microchip
live, on television and on the Web, in front
of them to confront the idea of analog memory
with digital memory, because a microchip records
information and in the context of the live
broadcast, one of the segments included a
reading of the microchip content inside my
body, both through the live program and the
Webcast.
[Women and men speaking polish speaking on
the video ]
So, the doctor who was assisting is asked
to describe what's going on and he says, almost
like narrating a soccer match, "Well, now
the artist is implanting a microchip and he
is slowly moving the needle and it's over
the skin. This was, he's narrating, cause
of course he was, he was afraid that he would
lose his license if he actually did the work
himself. So, he told me how to do this. Not
that I have the habit of using syringes. And
you see if you look behind him, you see the
seven sepia tone photographs on the wall.
So, this idea of confronting the changing
role of memory as everything becomes digital.
Analog memories are externalized, digital
memories become internalized, with the exception,
of course, that we also internalize analog
memories and, in this particular case, the
digital memory is retrieved. So, I had the
scanner connected to a robotic finger and
through the Web.
[Women and men speaking polish continues on
the video]
This is the third segment. So, I myself did
not know what the number was. The content
of the microchip is a sequence of nine digits,
which you see on the screen there. And I had
bought the six-pack, not of beer, but of microchips
and just picked one out of the box at the
last minute. So, I myself did not know what
the number was.
[Women and men speaking polish continues on
the video]
So, this, in '97, creating this work in which
tissue and microchips come together because
tissue forms around the microchip to secure
it in position. The microchip has biocompatible
glass. This question of digital, the digital
and the biological started to take center
stage for me and in '98, I wrote a text called
"Transgenic Art" more clearly signaling the
fact that I wanted to focus on the creation
of new life forms in the context of art. And
produced then, in 1999, my first transgenic
work called "Genesis."
[electronic music plays]
[bell chimes]
So, what is going on in this work? It's easier
to understand once we look at this diagram.
The starting point for me was the appropriation
of a passage from the Bible, from the book
of Genesis. I don't own a Bible, so I went
online, found the King James Version, copied
and pasted into Microsoft Word. And if you're
thinking James and combine that with Bill
Gates, that may be enough for a conceptual
artwork.
[laughter]
But I'm not a conceptual artist, so I persevered
and translated that to Morse code. Straightforward
Morse code, as you know, dots and dashes,
so what you see here under this arrow is a
direct Morse code translation of that passage
from the Bible, which is a significant passage
in the sense that this is where God gives
man total control over all life, and has been
down the drain from there, as you know. So,
inside the box, you see a code that I created
specifically for this work. On the left side,
you have the, what linguists call the motivated
section of the code. Because C, which represents
cytosine in DNA, is round and so is the dot,
so I established that analogy. And because
T is straight and so is the dash, I established
that analogy. On the right, you have the arbitrary
part of the code, so space between the letters
became guanine and space between words became
adenine. So, how does this work? You have
a direct translation, if you look at the bottom;
you have C-T-C-C-G. So, C-T-C-C is dot dash
dot dot space. And it goes on like that. So,
C-T-C-C, dot dash dot dot, is the letter L
that you have up here from the original English
text. The result is that the sequence of 360
genetic bases encodes the passage from the
Bible. So, when I'm doing this, I'm still
working on the computer screen and I have
a text file. So I copied from my text file,
pasted that into the email program and sent
that to a company specialized in DNA synthesis.
Two weeks later, I got a FedEx package with
the DNA. And you look at the DNA and it's
disembodied DNA and it becomes evident to
you that all this narrative that DNA has a
central and dominant position in controlling
life, when you see DNA outside of the body
it is very clear that without the body and
without the environment in which the body
is located, DNA cannot do anything. So, what
I created then was the Genesis bacteria, which
you see in this video. So now, if we look
at this again, it will make more sense.
[electronic music plays]
You come into the gallery, you see the Genesis
DNA sequence on one wall; a very large projection,
live from the Petri dish, which is in the
center. What you see now, the biblical passage,
which you see on the other wall. Behind you,
there is Morse. And here, the Web interface
that allows you to turn on a UV light source
in the gallery; from home or in the gallery
itself. And this is a short-wave UV, which
means that due to the high concentrated energy,
it causes real biological mutation in the
DNA. In other words, if this work is in Tokyo,
from New York you can change the word of God
in the body of the bacteria in Tokyo with
just one click. So, after the work was finished,
it premiered at Ars Electronica in 1999, I
took the bacteria back to the lab and read
the mutation and developed a series of works
with the mutant text in English because I
used the code to read it back to English.
Now, if you think about what this means, you
are encoding digital information into a living
organism. You are changing that and then you
are retrieving it. That's exactly what we
do with computers; input, processing and output,
except that you're doing that with a living
organism in real time. So, to me, that represents
certain significant aspects of life in the
21st Century in which, not only philosophically,
but materially, there is fundamentally really
no separation between digital and biological.
Processes can occur in similar manner in both
environments, in both media, if we can say
so. But of course, when you talk about the
living, when you talk about in the context
of art, creating an entirely new life form,
you have to recognize that you're not dealing
with an object because the life form that
you create is alive like you and I. So, it
shares the same properties of any living organism
and empathy and responsibility become paramount
in this context. And a good example of that
case is the second transgenic artwork that
I created called GFP Bunny. GFP Bunny is a
piece in which I used GFP, green fluorescent
protein, the DNA that codes for this protein,
that produces green light, and created a green
glowing bunny. There was an agreement between
myself and the lab that I commissioned to
make this work for me and the director of
the lab, at the very last minute, it was the
year 2000, you remember Doomsday, the apocalypse,
Y2K, everything satellites will fall, computers
will stop, it's the end of the world? Maybe
that played a role in his decision to censor
the work, but the fact is that that censorship
became very controversial. We have a four
minute clip that shows a bit of the controversy
around this work.
>>Male video narrator: This is the BBC World
service.
>>Female video narrator: Have you heard of
Alba the bunny? Alba lives at an agricultural
institute near Paris and she looks like any
other plain, old, white rabbit. Well, that's
until you put her under a blue light, at which
point, dear little Alba begins to glow green
and it's not in the name of science, before
you ask, but in the name of art.
>>ABC Male video narrator (Peter Jennings):
We touched on the genetic engineering controversy
earlier in the broadcast. When we saw this
story in yesterday's edition of the Boston
Globe, we thought, "Surely not." On the contrary,
surely. Here's ABC's Bill Blakemore.
>>Bill: Directors of the lab in France that
created the rabbit are not letting anyone
in to see it, but you can see a picture of
the rabbit, Alba, on the website of the artist
in Chicago, Eduardo Kac, who commissioned
the lab to create her.
>>Stuart Newman: When you start to genetically
engineer animals as part of an artwork, I
think that you're really beginning to cross
a line that isn't necessary to cross.
>>Bill: But animal rights groups say that
Alba's artistic visibility may publicize her
plight as a lab animal.
>>Lisa Lange: If this has been highlighted
in this experiment then it is helpful for
laboratory animals everywhere.
>>Male BBC Video narrator: Email us at this
address, alcookbbc.co.uk. It's time now to
talk about a rabbit that's got a few people
into a bit of a stew. That's because this
rabbit is the center of a project that sparked
off a debate involving art and science. Spell
out, if you will, the artistic message of
this project.
>>Kac: Well, there are several messages, but
one of them is the fact that Alba, like any
other transgenic animal, has a cognitive and
emotional life that must be acknowledged in
a social space.
[jazz type music]
>>man from video #1: Who plays God in the
21st century? It looks like you and your buddies
do, huh? Rabbits, you know, have existed in
for how many billions of years and why do
you think you're so important that you can
mess with it? I think you're a pawn of these
biotechnology companies and I'm sure you probably
didn't have to pay very much for this to happen.
I'm sure they loved to tally it as another
one of their successes.
>>man from video #2: When ancestral man picked
up a stone and called it a tool, we radically
changed this planet. Ever since that time,
ok? And when we accepted the line from Genesis
that we hold dominion over all the animals
and the fish of the sea, as a society, this
is generally what we do. All societies, and
we must question each and every technological
advance and we haven't done a good job of
it and I'm glad that you are doing this project
to bring these issues to the forefront to
produce these forums when we can't hash these
problems out because, prior to this, there
isn't enough discussion.
[applause]
[upbeat music plays]
>>Male NPR announcer: This is wait, wait,
don't tell me. The NPR News Quiz.
>>Male NPR Host: So, you're ready to play
here?
>>man #3: Sure.
>>NPR Host: All right, here's your first limerick.
>>NPR announcer: Old Noah cried out, "Oh,
dagnabit, we really must learn to cohabit.
If you glow in the dark, come on down to the
ark. I've got space for a mutant, green"
>>man #3: Rabbit?
>>NPR Host: Yes.
[bell rings]
Unbelievable as it may sound, it's true. Alba
is an albino rabbit that, under regular light,
just looks furry and cute, but turn on the
black light--
>>Kac: So, this gives us a sense of the kinds
of conversations, debates, discourses that
have been generated around this work, which
was part of my intention originally. And basically
to conclude, I will point out that because
of the censorship and the particular nature
of the reception of this work, which has been
going on for ten years, I have developed a
whole series of works under the rubric of
Rabbit Remix. But the one that I would like
to present to, to close my presentation tonight
is this one called La Googleglyph. And I am
very thankful to Scott and Nina for their
help in making this a reality. So, in January
of this year, I created this work initially
and I looked at this satellite from a company
called Digital Globe, which is one of the
company's that Google uses for Google Earth
and this satellite, called WorldView 2 had
blown up at that point. And I studied it and
came to the conclusion that the satellite
sees the world in grids of pixels that measure
50 centimeters. So, I created a blogoglyph,
which is a series from the Rabbit Remix that
has this bunny image, using pixels measuring
50 centimeters. So, here I am standing on
the roof of the building where I had my exhibition
and we have the work now visible. It was created
specifically for this satellite. So, let's
see if we can zoom in and actually see it
through Google Earth itself. It is my goal
to basically create La Googleglyphs all over
the planet and allow us, with just a few clicks
to zoom in and see them. Hold on. There. There
it is.
[laughter]
And, into the eye of the storm. There we go.
Thanks.
[applause]
>>presenter: We have a few minutes for questions
for Eduardo. All the way in the back.
>>Male audience member #1: So, I think that
obviously the rabbit thing [inaudible]. I
guess I was a little more angry with myself,
too, when you described it there until I realized
[inaudible]. I guess I really do kind of have
questioned the empathy of working with an
animal who can't choose to make that decision.
My own kind of moral test is would I do that
to a family member or loved one? I would say,
you know, a family member or a loved one wanted
to do that themselves, but if they didn't
have an ability to choose then [inaudible]
I guess I question whether you were true to
the rabbit when it couldn't really choose
it and would you advocate even given then
positive benefits to animal research or any
testing would not want to draw the plight
of criminals in the United States to light
by making [inaudible].
>>presenter: How would you respond?
>>Kac: Sure. This comment gives me the opportunity
to clarify a very important point. Is that
you don't take an existing rabbit and modify
it. That's impossible. So, the work you do,
you do in the microscope with a single cell.
You, pretty much, you combine transgenics
with IVF. So, basically, you have the egg
and then you have the male reproductive cell
inside the egg and it is in the male reproductive
cell, just one single cell, that you introduce
the DNA. So, there is no rabbit there that
you introduce. I understand that for, if we're
not familiar with the process, we might picture
something cruel that you take a bunny and
you inject something to it, but it's not like
that at all. We work in the microscope with
an individual cell and then you're bringing
into the world a healthy bunny. So, it's a
very different process. And the other aspect
of this is that it is intrinsic to life that
the life that comes into the world does so
by a process that is developed by a previous
generation or by another living being. In
other words, no single life form in the world
ever has the choice to come into the world.
It's always a decision, say, of our parents
or if it's a non-human, it's a decision of
a human, so it is always, in this case there's
no exception. The decision is always made
by others. The question here is bringing into
the world a life form that did not exist before
and then we're back to the beginning of your
comment, which has to do with the responsibility
and ethics. That is why, for me, it was absolutely
indispensible to bring the bunny home so that
I could be personally responsible for it and
when the censorship came, I started a whole
campaign to free the bunny and I went back
to Paris. I spent nine days in Paris every
day mobilizing public opinion, and I created
a flag, and I gave public talks, and I tried
to work with the lab, and once it became clear
that that was not going to happen, rather
than succumbing and accepting what they wanted,
which was to make Alba disappear, then I continued
to develop a whole series of works to keep
her virtually alive so that her memory would
not be erased by those who tried to make her
disappear.
>>Male audience member #1: Whatever happened
to Alba?
>>Kac: She never left the lab. And rabbits
usually live, on average, eight years. So,
it's ten now.
>>Female audience member #1: Do you still
have that microchip in your ankle?
>>Kac: I do.
>>member #2: Has it ever come in handy?
>>Kac: No, but it, if you're wondering if
it makes airports sound alarms, it does not.
My belt has more metal than the microchip.
But next time, if you remind me, next time
I'll bring the scanner and you can scan it.
>>presenter: [inaudible]. Any more questions
for Eduardo?
>>Kac: Thank you. One more?
>>Male audience member#2: Hi, I was wondering
about the all the process of how you transcoded
the passage of the Bible into Morse code and
how that was transcoded to DNA code, I got
lost because the bacteria that was created
out of that or from that?
>>Kac: Sure. See, the way you do this is you
take the DNA and you insert that DNA in what
is called a plasmid. A plasmid is a ring of
DNA at this point, you find it in nature,
but at this point is engineered with areas
specifically for you to insert the DNA that
you're interested in working with. So, you
move your DNA into the plasmid, the plasmid
goes into the bacterium, basically in a solution;
it's pretty mechanical, really. It's a solution
that makes the bacteria open up and in that
liquid it, the plasmid just naturally moves
in. And how do you know that all bacteria
have actually accepted your DNA? The plasmid
has also a sequence that endows the bacterium
to resistance to antibiotics. In other words,
after you do that work, you put the bacteria
in another medium with antibiotics. Those,
that's what you're doing, pretty much straight
forward Darwinian selection at that point.
Those that have accepted your DNAs survive
and those that didn't just don't.
>>member #3: You killed the bacteria.
>>Kac: I do, yes. I do. And another way that
you see it is there is another sequence in
there, which allows the bacteria to glow with
the same gene that Alba glows. So, you do
this first phase to select and then you have
confirmation because all you have to do is
put the Petri dish on a UV light box and boom.
If they glow, you see that they accepted your
plasmid.
>>presenter: Yes.
>>member #4: Does anyone like, dog breeders
or horse breeders, can anyone step forward
if [inaudible] we breed for these other [inaudible].
>>Kac: No, and the at one point the media
never really talked about because obviously
they're more interested in selling papers
than really disclosing how this works, is
that Alba doesn't glow all the time. If she
was walking here, she wouldn't be glowing
because you absolutely must have two things
to see the glow. One is a blue light of a
very specific frequency because the GFP protein
and the source have to go together. There
are several kinds of lights, several kinds
of proteins, they have to go together. So,
it has to be a very specific frequency of
blue for that particular protein. That's one
thing. And for you to see, you need to do
so through a yellow filter because you gotta
block the blue light, otherwise you're gonna
have, she's albino, so otherwise you're gonna
have blue and white and that's what you're
gonna see. You gotta block the blue and then
you can see the green emission. And, of course,
this is never mentioned. Ok, thanks.
[applause]
>>presenter: Next up we have Andrew Senior
who is a British artist, living and working
in New York, in sculpture and electronic art.
He is exhibited internationally including
an honorable mention at PreVida 8.0, the BlindArt
Foundation Prize, and Madrid Abierto, 2008.
He has co-chaired the ACM Multi Media Conference
Arts Track and Andrew Senior's art is informed
by his technical research in human-computer
interaction, multimedia and computer vision,
for which he holds several patents and is
published extensively. He currently works
on speech recognition in the research group
at Google, here in New York City.
[applause]
>>Andrew: Thank you very much, Scott. So,
today I'd like to talk about the piece that
I have in this exhibition, which is Couch
Potato Farm, and after I've spoken, Sandra
will talk about the piece that I worked with
her and Jason Weston on, called Refugium.
That was a collaborative effort. But I'll
talk about Couch Potato Farm first. And like
Scott himself and Eduardo, I got interested
in artificial life projects a few years ago
and Couch Potato Farm was my first work investigating
artificial life. Previously, I'd worked in
steel sculpture and landscape art and then
started to transition to electronic works.
These are some of the previous works and then
I started to think about artificial life and
we've just seen some of the most important
work in artificial life. But artificial life
covers a wide range of types of art, including
biological experimentation, like we've just
seen, robotic systems that behave like living
creatures, or computer simulation of life
and that's what Couch Potato Farm is. It's
an electronic simulation of an ecosystem.
So, I imagined what would life be like if
it could live in television signals, instead
of living in the real world? And we have all
these different sources of electromagnetic
radiation that surround us all the time. Increasingly,
we have Wi-Fi, television, radio, cellular
telephones, we still don't really know the
effects that they have on real life, but this
initial work now in capturing the energy from
television transmissions to power electronic
devices. So, we do actually have now examples
of life that is powered by television signals.
But I wondered what would happen if we could
actually have an ecosystem that lived within
the television signals? So, I created Couch
Potato Farm that is a virtual ecosystem that
watches television. So, it's a software system
into which I feed a television signal from
a television tuner. So, this is an example
image from a television program and it lives
off the television signal and you can see
its effects by it's, it changes the television
signal. So, if we had a clean transmission
we'd see the image on the left, but after
the ecosystem has extracted some of the energy
from that television signal, then we get an
image, a distorted image on the right. And
you can see the work in the back corner of
the lobby here running on a series of programs
just from live television. So, I wanted to
explain a little bit about how the system
works. It takes in television signals from
the TV tuner and then processes them through
two kinds of artificial life systems. One
is a cellular automaton, which is similar
to Conway's Life. So, this is an earlier example
of a computer program that, in some sense,
simulates life. It takes the state of one
time, applies the series of rules, and then
generates a new state. And the basic domain
of my Couch Potato Farm is a cellular automaton,
like this, that lives off the television signals.
So, it takes in red, green and blue energies
in each pixel and now it has three layers
instead of this single layer like Conway's
Life. And adjacent cells affect each other,
but they're also affected by the external
signal. So, where we have a lot of blue, then
we'll get very strong blue potatoes I call
them in this field because they watch television
all the time. And that blue, if you have a
strong blue potato in a particular pixel,
then it will tend to drain out the color from,
the blue color from the television signal.
So, what you see in the affected television
has the blue color drained out. And so we
have a time delay as we see one color, then
that gets drained out of subsequent images.
Then I hypothesized another part of the ecosystem,
which were animals, which were mobile creatures
that can move around within the ecosystem
and they would interact. They would feed off
the potatoes as they moved around and interact
with each other. So, there are four species
in this ecosystem. Particular animals eat
other animals of different species, or they
mate with animals of the same species and
opposite gender. And they also affect the
television signal in different ways to produce
an affected video.
[pause]
I guess you'll have to look at the work itself.
This video isn't working on this display.
And so, the animals are encoded with a genetic
algorithm. So, every time they mate, then
they produce offspring with potential mutations
and a combination of the genes of the two
parents. And the genes encode a variety of
factors, including the speed of the animals,
their longevity, the range at which they can
detect other animals of the same or different
species. And so, as an ecosystem watches a
particular program, then you'll get a particular
convergence on a solution that works for that
television program. And as the program changes,
then you'll get a different population arising
that matches the characteristics the new program.
So, when the animals mate, then they're, the
mother is static for awhile and then produces
a new child which has the genes spliced from
the two parents with some possible mutation.
So, this is an earlier video that shows, this
is showing the original signal at the bottom
right and the potato field in the larger image
with the strong colors that it adapted based
on the colors that have been seen in the previous
images in the original signal. Then as we
go along, we'll see the affected signal. Here's
the affected signal with patches of color
drained out from the original signal based
on the presence of the, this potato field.
And then finally here we have the field with
the creatures moving around, eating the potatoes
and leaving trails of blackness. The large
image here is just the animals themselves
in isolation visualized. And then here we
have the affected TV, which is what you see
on the monitor in the exhibition. So, the
animals have these auras around them which
are affecting the TV. In this case, they're
brightening the images; they're also delaying
through time. So, presenting a television
from the past and also shifting the television
image effects that surround the presence of
the creatures. And then finally, I wanted
to talk about one other work that I've done
which is another artificial life piece called
Earthwords, which imagines what would words
be if they were alive, and how do texts come
about by imagining that individual words could
be alive. And it imagines handwritten words
as organisms, moving around and particular
words have affinities to each other based
on their presence in an original text. So,
[pause]
so this shows the initial text, but I took,
which is a piece by Derrida talking about
signs and inscriptions on monuments and I
had taken that this is the origin which defines
the affinities between the words and then
we'll move into a different screen which actually
imagines the words as alive and interacting
with each other. And as this comes up I can
take questions.
>>presenter: Ok.
>>Andrew: Thank you very much and then Sandra
will talk about her joint work next.
>>presenter: Are there questions for Andrew?
>>Male audience member #5: Is it the cycle
of couch potatoes, how, it's continuous? Does
it reboot itself or start over?
>>Andrew: It does have, it can reset. If all
the creatures die out then I restart the ecosystem,
with a new set of initial conditions.
>>member #5: What we're seeing here is live,
right?
>>Andrew: So, in this case, I switched the
work to HD for this exhibition and I haven't
yet got the HD running live up 30 frames a
second, so this is actually stored video,
but the idea is it can run live but not in
HD at the moment.
>>member #5: [inaudible]
>>Andrew: As, as an artwork, as a display
on the wall and ideally it would be running
live. I mean, making progress and making it
faster to run in real time on live signals
and in an earlier implementation, you could
also have conditions in the ecosystem that
will actually change the channels so that
they, the creatures could actually change
the channel based on their genetic makeup
and the conditions in the ecosystem.
>>presenter: Any more questions?
>>Male audience member #6: I have one. Do
you see it as feasible that life forms could
evolve, like, let's just say for example,
you have a virus, virus is being mutated and
grow and [inaudible].
>>Andrew: I, yes, potentially computer viruses.
This, Couch Potato Farm, is completely a figment
of my imagination, but potentially with, if
people coded genetic algorithms into the virus
that's on the, could spread themselves, then
yeah. But I think they would have to be encoded
deliberately. So, this is the Earthwords showing
the words crawling around and as they find
words to which they have an affinity, then
they actually lock together and form a joint
phrase. Here, we see "a" and "monument" which
could go together in the original text and
now they become a single creature, which will
now crawl around the environment looking for
other words they were adjacent to in the original
piece.
>>member #6: Does it ultimately resolve?
>>Andrew: No, because they also can fall apart
as well. Just randomly, they disconnect when
they get very large. Ok, thank you.
[applause]
>>presenter: Next up is Sandra Cordero, who
also lives and works in New York. She studied
animation and painting at New York University
and Hunter College. Her work has been shown
at the Queens Museum of Art and at films festivals
across the country. She is a member of the
Sperm Whale Collective, which creates interactive
installations and visuals at events throughout
the Northeast.
>>Sandra: Thank you. Volume good? In the back?
Yes? Hi, so, I'm Sandra. I'm going to talk
about Refugium 1 & 2, which is the piece in
the room back there. It was collaboration
between myself, Andrew, who you just met,
and Jason, who also works at Google. A Refugium
is a haven for populations of flora and fauna
which were previously more widespread. And
just to give you an idea of the timeline for
this, we started working on this in July.
We made this piece specifically for this exhibition.
We wanted to combine traditional media with
digital art. So the idea was that I would
contribute paintings, which would then be
used as jpegs and then Andrew and Jason would
create visual effects to manipulate the images.
We got the theme of the show, which was gonna
be the future, which got us thinking what
natures gonna look like many, many years from
now. And we wanted to find a way of conveying
this by mixing painting and video. So, we
came up with the idea that I would create
a painting of a forest scene. Andrew had this
idea of trees in a forest seen from below
and then putting effects on the image so that
you get the sense of leaves moving in the
breeze and Jason was more interested in what
ocean life would be like in the future, so
he wanted to work with marine, a marine painting
where he would create effects that evoke the
motion of waves in the sea. Prior work and
inspiration, I know for me, personally, I
really like Jacco Oliviers work. He does really
large animated paintings which he then projects
onto a wall and The Sperm Whale is a collective
that Jason and I are members of which mixes
traditional and digital art. For example,
in this image the drawings were made in pastel
on paper, scanned in, and then animated digitally
using Orco, which is an Open Source program
written by members of The Sperm Whale. And
as we were discussing how we, this was gonna
be displayed, like what kind of screens we'd
mount it on, how we were going to show it,
we just started wondering, "Well, what would
happen if we projected onto the paintings
themselves, instead of using flat screens?
Well, what would that look like?" So, we started
making some rough drafts. Andrew wrote the
first test in processing, which is an Open
Source, Java-based graphics language. This
is a still photo that he used to manipulate
in the rough draft, where the leaves are moving
very subtly. The final version was written
in C++ with OpenGL and also used some code
from Orco, which is another graphics-based
language. And everything in that you see in
the next room is being rendered real-time.
This is the painting that Jason used for one
of his rough drafts that I did of spiny lobsters.
Spiny lobsters have been around for millions
of years; longer than humans. And they'll
probably be around for millions of years after
we're gone. They're getting along just fine
without us. And this is a draft of him projecting
effects onto the painting. We were playing
around with having the projection bleed beyond
the edges of the canvas and make an animated
border. So, meanwhile, I just happened to
be having a trip booked to visit my mother,
who lives in Wisconsin. And she just happens
to live in a forest and this is a photo of
her backyard. So, I spent a few days just
taking photos, sketching a lot of the plant
life out there and then when I got back to
New York, I make made some compositional layouts
just to get an idea. This is the first one.
I was inspired by all these really weird alien-looking
fungus that were growing in the logs and tree
trunks in the forest. The second idea, I was
thinking of a swampy future where we've created
so much global warming that we have these
mutant Venus flytraps that you see at the
bottom of the screen, that are just eating
up every protein source they can find in their
environment. And the third one, which is the
one we all agreed was the most successful,
was also the most at keeping with Andrew's
original idea of looking up through the leaves
in a forest. It's a mix of domestic and wild
vegetation. This is the painting that was
created from it. You can see, for example,
the chartreuse leaves at the bottom are inspired
from my mom's rhododendrons. Next to them,
are leaves based on sketches of weeds I took
that were growing in the driveway. And some
of them I took more liberty with like the
purple thistle things. I wanted to see what
they would look like in the future. I wanted
to keep that sense of a much warmer environment,
where you've got a lot of humidity's and you
see the sun through yellow haze and the pollen
just hanging in this really thick air. So,
while I was doing that, the Jason and Andrew
writing the effects, which were then used
on jpegs which I took of the paintings. They
wrote ten different effects, which are cycling
through randomly and the effects change every
ten minutes. Four of the effects chop up the
image into hot blocks and then these patches
are moved around randomly, or using a sine
wave over time. So, you can get that effect
of leaves in the wind or of an ocean wave
moving over the image. Two of the effects
work on the contrast in color of the image
and change it slowly over time. Three of the
effects take pixels of the same color and
drop them down the canvas at a speed which
is a function of their color. So, certain
colors move faster, slower and it creates
this effect of the image melting. And there's
one colorful effect where it starts out black
and then the image fills in based on the color.
Like, different colors have different starting
points and then when the image is completely
filled in, it starts fading to black again.
And so once this was ready, we installed it.
I think it was Andrew who had the idea to
use one projector for both images, just to
help with installing. And then they had to
write a program to tweak the placement of
the projected images so that they aligned
with the paintings because we didn't want
them, we decided we didn't want the projection
bleeding onto the wall behind the canvas.
And it was, and we had to figure out a way
of compensating for the key stoning of the
projected image. So, yeah I think it was an
interesting experience for viewers, people
have said. How is it working? Like, they didn't
quite get, they thought, some people thought
that the image was emanating from the painting
and some people would look around and say,
"Where's the projector?" Or, "Where's the
other projectors?" So, I think it was successful
in that sense, in combining traditional and
digital art together. Yeah, any questions?
[pause]
Nice. Thank you.
[applause]
>>presenter: Our last speaker of the evening
is Marina Zurkow, who is a video and media
artist whose works have taken the form of
multi-channel videos, customized multi-screen
computer pieces, performative and interactive
works. Her recent animated psychological narratives
address humans and their relationships to
animals, plants and the weather. Since 2000,
Zurkow has exhibited at the Sundance Film
Festival, Rotterdam Film Festival, The Soul
Media City Biennial, Ars Electronica, The
Creative Time, The Kitchen, The Walker Art
Center, The National Museum for Women in the
Arts and Eyebeam, among other venues. She
has been New York Foundation for the Arts
Fellow, a Rockefeller New Media Fellow and
a Creative Capital Grantee. Zurkow is on the
faculty of NYU's Interactive Technology Program
( ITP) and lives in Brooklyn. She is represented
by Wulkowitz Gallery in New York.
[applause]
>>Marina: This is an unexpected prop, this
mic, so I'm gonna juggle my text. I'm gonna
try to really stick to this text so I don't
start blathering. So, last year I completed
a body of 11 works that fall under this title,
"Crossing the Waters." The works were made
between 2006 and 2009 and the pieces thematically
address climate change. And in each of these
works, I took a fairly different approach
to the material, somewhere between moving
paintings and psychological narrative. So,
a few things about this series. The works
are all very long, slow loops and they are
unconventionally formatted for moving images,
often displayed on custom-built multi-monitor
units. Many of them are hung on the wall.
They have plug and play custom computing parts
and so on. The intention of the work is to
create these pieces that you would end up
living with. They're not linear pieces, they're
meant to be seen over, anywhere from, some
pieces run 9 to 20 minutes, or had been running
9 to 20 minutes. And here's just another example
of some smaller works from Bryce Wolkowitz
Gallery. Often, the pieces are designed modularly,
so I've reformatted them. In this case, they've
been scaled up installation context in a institution.
The same piece, here, you can see in Croatia
in a gallery called "Grey Area" and this was
a, this is a gallery that only exists in this
villa doorway and is meant to be seen from
boats passing by. This is the original format
for the pieces out in the lobby, Slurb, and
it was commissioned by the city of Tampa for
an outdoor Biennial festival called Lights
on Tampa and exhibited there in 2009. So,
I thought, I'm not gonna show the piece because
obviously, it's out there and I hope that
you'll have a chance to see it and listen
to the soundtrack, which you can only hear
through the headphones out there, but the
soundtrack is pretty key to the piece. It's
an 18 minute loop and a seamless 18 minute
loop. So, I thought I'd use the piece though,
to describe a process of constructing the
work that I make and use Slurb as a model
to demonstrate that. First of all, almost
all of the projects in this series are rotoscoped
and rotoscoping is an animation technique
where you draw directly on top of video material,
frame by frame. In my case, the work is completely
hand done. And the second thing I wanna say
is that, despite the fact that the works look
like extremely unified pictures, they are
actually a collage, cobbled together from
really disparate sources. Many of the works
have a futuristic, or fantastic, tone to them,
but all of the source material for the rotoscoping
was found on the Internet, a space that I'd
call in itself an inter-dependent ecosystem,
and a space in which you find both competing
and complementary mean pools. All the footage
I use is real, in other words, and it might
resonate as something you've saw somewhere
before, from new sites, from Google searches,
YouTube and so on. The third thing is that
nearly all of the elements in these works
are composed as loops. Because I work alone
most of the time, and hand drawn animation
is labor intensive, using looped character
behavior is very economical and efficient.
But these loops also have a really distinct
stutter to them. They're very imperfect and
that adds or breaks the seamless rendered
space that these pieces seems to exude and
create a kind of a brokenness. Finally, I
look at these works as ambient moving paintings,
more of a narrative cartoons. And they're
reminiscent of Asian scroll paintings in both
their formats and the way that the landscape
is moved across the screen. What you're looking
at here is almost half of the story board
for Slurb, and the 18 minute length of the
piece was determined by just a simple empirical
process of seeing how long it would take to,
in a generous fashion, move this story board
across the picture plane. Tampa is the site
that you see in Slurb that's half submerged.
And the piece itself really looked at the
Gulf of Mexico's changing ecology, while speculating
on the reality of this present day return
to a primordial sea, and what that kind of
a return to an older, more primitive form
of sea, what might mean if you mixed together
all of these new, speculative societies. Tampa
and the entire Gulf coast, including New Orleans,
is at risk for flooding of the Gulf. It occurs
during hurricane season and the volume of
these conditions is worsening from climate
change. For Lights on Tampa, I wanted to make
a piece that addressed this and to create
a confluence of facts and speculations that
were specific to the Gulf coast, but also
global in scope. The Gulf and the Southern
Atlantic Coast used to have a healthy shrimp
fishing industry, but pollutants, agricultural
run-off, over-fishing, and ocean warming,
have worldwide altered the oceans' chemical
balance, rendering it acid and deprived of
oxygen. The result isn't only a significant
decrease in diversity, but also a phenomenon
referred to as "the rise of slime." Slime
being toxic algae, jellyfish, and other more
primitive forms of sea life. And these are
forms that survive really well in the aforementioned
conditions of an epoxic ocean. So, these trawling
boats used to be fitted for shrimp catches
and they've now been reconfigured to catch
jellyfish for the Asian market, where they're
considered a delicacy. To explore this story
of a transformed ecology, I wanted to transpose
class and cultural concerns and ask questions
about who and how might thrive in these new
conditions. I started to research my cast
of characters, looking for ways to soften
this relatively unpleasant scenario. I wanted
to make something that had the feeling J.J.
Grandville's 19th Century satirical illustrations,
creating hybrid creatures and car wrecked
mermaids and a macabre Steven King chorus
that had some traces of ethnographic portraiture
and that also mined a rich history of traditionally
aquatic and contemporary water-based lifestyles.
So, I became interested in portraying contemporary
people accustomed to living on the water,
like the members of the Intha tribe that you
see in these images. They live in Myanmar
and they live in a, not only Myanmar, there's
other similar aquatic communities in Cambodia
and Vietnam, but many of them now, the lakes
that they've lived on for hundreds of years
in this way and they live in houseboats and
they farm hydroponically, they're, it's become
quite unsustainable cause their waterways
have also become polluted by some of the same
things that I described are happening in the
oceans. So, this is, for instance, a hydroponic
raft-based hydroponic farm system from this
community. I was also really interested in
the optimistic design of these amphibious
houses. These are being implemented in the
Netherlands and also I was really interested
in this tailgate party from hell scenario.
So you can get a sense of all of that in the
piece, I think. And I think this is a picture
from Morpeth, England, from the floods from
two years ago. This was from a very, very
small river, very heavy rains and utterly
shocked the community. They've never really
experienced anything like this. So, this is
a fairly, it's a reality. It's not that far
to speculate. Finally, with Slurb, I wanted
to make a travel narrative, one that unfolded
like a Chinese scroll and circled around continuously
like a carousel, one that would take you from
the city of Tampa and follow its landmarks
out past the broken highways and into the
suburbs and then back around again. This is
actually one of the first 11 centuries, 12
century scroll from Japan, animal scroll.
This is also very long. This is the site of
the projection for Slurb. Across the plaza
from Tampa's ice hockey stadium was the parking
lot. Well, here. This is the parking lot that's
across from this building on the right and
fortunately, during the week that the piece
was projected, the circus was in town and
so, every evening at dusk, when the projector
would fire up, coincidentally, the elephants
would have to walk across the plaza and into
the ice hockey stadium. So it really had this
kind of pop off the screen effect, because
if you hear the music, there's a kind of a
circus theme or a really distorted circus
theme that's under, that underlines it. So
when I made Slurb, there wasn't the same kind
of public upset around the health of the Gulf
of Mexico as there is post the British Petroleum
disaster and now Slurb is encoded with a very
different resonance as I experienced in May
in Austin, when I showed the work. And the
really disturbing thing was in Texas, where
people were, it was, it was the oil was imminent
and there was a real sense with the piece
and I, it was up, I was there for a week in
residence and so I spoke to a lot of different
kinds of people. And disturbingly, the response
was how comforting this piece was to them
because they felt like, look at your eyes,
they felt like this piece demonstrated our
adaptability and that in the end, we would
all be ok.
[laughter]
Yeah. I thought, "Wow. Ten gone, ten left."
Ok. I'm gonna jump ahead actually, and show
a little bit of a new work. So, I can take
my time with this cause its 144 hours long.
[laughter]
So, this piece is called "Mezacausim, North
Umberland, United Kingdom." And it's an animated
landscape representing one year of real time
on the moors of Northern England. It's the
first in a series of works that use data inputs,
or algorithms, to determine the activities
you see on screen. This piece runs as 144
hour cycle, 146 hour cycle. I'm sorry, my
math is really terrible. Animated objects
were placed on a stage and code determines
the frequency and order of their appearance.
No cycle is identical to the last as the characters
and seasonal weather are determined by a simple
probability equation. One hour of world time
elapses in each minute of screen time. Because
of the long duration of the events unfolding,
Mezacausim is ideally meant to be seen by
passers-by in public space, or if you left
your web browser open constantly, I suppose
that would also be a good way to see the work.
Where one might become invested in the fate
of the protagonist on a summer's eve, and
be surprised 72 hours later when it's snowing
and the animated field is full of refugees.
The title "Mezacausim" is drawn from the field
of environmental science and refers to experimental,
simulated ecosystems that allow for manipulation
of the physical environment for "organismal,
community and ecological research." Mezacausim,
North Umberland is the first in this series,
which will include an array of landscapes
that use different data strategies to determine
their unfolding. The landscapes include Tsujiki,
the largest fish market in the world in Tokyo,
a depleted oil field in Texas, a horse racetrack
and a farm that grows animals for pharmacological
purposes. These landscapes reflect common
global concerns while being geographically
distinct and culturally specific. Each site
evinces a particular and heavy dependence
on resources, is an extreme example of managed
nature, which is definitely the case. Oh,
this is awesome that he gets up. He doesn't
get up very often and so, sometimes I've shown
this piece and he's just sitting there the
entire time. People just say like, "I don't
really understand what's going on. This piece
doesn't, nothing really ever happens." Sorry
to interrupt myself, but--
[laughter]
It's very exciting. So, the landscapes reflect
common global concerns while being geographically
distinct, culturally specific and each site
is evidence of a particular heavy dependency
on resources. An extreme example of managed
nature or possesses a rich cultural or mythological
history and embodies a tension between the
magically real and the pathologically monetized.
So, I think that's really all I wanna say
today, but I thought maybe I could just leave
this running. If you had any questions, I'd
be happy to answer them.
[applause]
Yes.
>>Male audience member #7: So, there's this
[inaudible].
>>Marina: I've never really heard those pitched
against each other, but.
>>member #7: [inaudible].
>>Marina: Well, it's really; I worked on this
for the last year. I'm pretty much done. I
have some code tweaks and some other things
that I need to finish in the piece, but A.
the piece is a black hole. It'll just absorb
anything I put into it. There are a couple
hundred animated characters and weather instances
in the piece. There's snow and wind and different
animals at different seasons. And it's, and
there's machinery, farm machinery and refugees.
There's a lot of stuff in this piece and I
at the same time felt that the piece was incredibly
boring. And in a way, it is, and I've made
a commitment to producing a truly ambient
work that you don't know where it's in the
front and where its, where things are the
subject or the object of the work. And it's
something that I've become really interested
in. And there's a book I'm very keen on called
"Ecology Without Nature" by Timothy Morton,
who's a literary critic, an eco-critic and
who talks a lot about sound art and producing
this literally ambivalent world in which there's
things that are in foreground and in the background,
they sort of shift space. And so, I'm very
interested in that as a kind of response to
the noisy, fast, crazy, very clearly defined
space in which we mostly occupy; the subjective
position. So, I have to stand behind this
experiment and hope for the best. It's a long
answer to that question in terms of how do
I push back. I feel like I am pushing the
boundaries of my own tolerance and hopefully,
this has resonance for other people. Especially
when I think you see more than one of these.
This is the first one and it's, it's such
a weird choice. I had a residence last summer
in Northern England, so I, and I went there,
really, to do this kind of nature 2.0, really
very reconfigured view of what nature and
our relationship to the natural world is,
and had gone as a researcher and this was
one of the outcomes. The other outcome is
I'm doing a performance piece there where
producing food made out of invasive species,
which is, and producing them as kind of ethnic
food stuffs, for many reasons because there's
a very intense connection between rhetoric
around invasive species and rhetoric around
race. So, these have become in tandem in a
way with other manifestations that are more
direct. These are very much about mediation
and narratives; stories that we tell ourselves
about the natural world and so, I'm not sure
what I'm doing but I know for certain I'm
finished with that work. So, it seems like
a kind of new exploration.
>>Male audience member #8: Just following
up on his question about how do you know if
it's successful or not? How do you describe
how there are so many elements potentially
involved with the piece, that could seem to
be pure chaos [inaudible]. There's a simplicity
to it, that might be the potential for all
the chaos.
>>Marina: Yeah, well you know it's interesting
because I come from film and this extremely
linear authored old-fashioned mentality about
making and a question is how much can I give
that up and how much can I let accident really
happen in this space? And one thing I'm not
really, I'm interested in bringing in more
procedurally produced elements into this work.
I think some of the weather components start
to look like that anyway and there's no reason
why they're not being produced algorithmically,
but I'm not willing to relinquish my hand
in the 2D space, which demands order, layering,
a sense, it's artifice of perspective and
a sense of pictorial cohesion. So, that, in
a way, is what has saved it, but is also what,
I think, is in the end a limitation on this
system that I'm proposing. And I, again, I
don't know where this is gonna go in a couple
years. I have no idea. Yes?
>>Male audience member #9: What's driving
the piece? Are these autonomous agents, these
elements?
>>Marina: Oh gosh, nothing that fancy.
[Marina laughs]
They're independent swfs and they're, there
are monthly buckets so there's a bucket for
January, February, March and then each of
those is divided into a dawn, day, dusk and
night. And in each of those timeframes, there's
a probability number, a percentage that says
this will come out. Super simple.
>>member #9: Like the birds just flew out.
>>Marina: Mm-hmm.
>>member #9: Now, if they flew out, feasibly
they could have flown out, he wouldn't be
sitting there. And they would've landed on
him, right?
>>Marina: Yeah, but the piece is very, he
is always sitting there when the birds come
and, they eat him in the summer. They peck
at his flesh. And the squirrels, oh, here's
the squirrels. So, the squirrels eat him also.
They only come out when he's sitting there,
so he only leaves at night. So, now it's the
workaround.
>>member #9: Every time, let's say, two birds
come out, are they gonna land on him and do
the same thing?
>>Marina: Well, there's a bunch of them, but
yes. Currently there's not anything more sophisticated
than--
>>member #9: They're not running in their
own--
>>Marina: No, they're, they're placed on an
X-Y in the stage, so they're, this is super
compromise. I feel guilty having to confess
that, but--
[laughter]
Good.
>>Male audience member #10: So, it seems like
you've come to terms with the fact that you
don't enjoy watching [inaudible] works in
a gallery setting. I mean, nobody really,
I mean, I've never really seen a successful
marketing in that people go into the gallery
and they watch the entire work through. Because
it's not meant for it, you walk in and it's
at a random point.
>>Marina: Right.
>>member #10: I mean your works designed around
that idea that people could come and [inaudible].
So what are some other successful ways [inaudible]?
I mean some spaces they have these special
[inaudible] more like a movie theater.
>>Marina: Right, like Eve Sussman has an 83
minute piece up about Alczar with a screening
schedule. Yeah.
>>member #10: So, I mean what ways can you
as artists have to deal with that scenario?
>>Marina: Well, I mean, it's funny because
this wouldn't even work in a gallery. This
needs to be in a different kind of public
space with regular, commuter space, it's perfect
for. Because if you saw this, it's even hard
to show this here. I have to explain this
machination or show you little bits and pieces
or can some experiences for you, but you don't
get a sense of really, I mean it's great,
but a dump truck came out. But who knows what's
really gonna happen and so these are spaces
that are meant to be seen with very long periods
of passing by or waiting. Or loitering. So,
this isn't even a good, this isn't a good
gallery solution.
>>member #10: But it is for somebody, then,
you'd have to buy and take it home to.
>>Marina: Well, yeah, it's great if you want
it in your living room, sure. Oh, yes I see
what you're saying, but I don't know, it's
this sounds like a very complicated, longer
conversation about what galleries or how their
willing to represent work and how to, is this
interesting or not to sell on the part of
a dealer. So, we're a particularly biased
community, sitting in this room, interested
in these issues.
>>Female audience member #11: Do you draw
all the characters?
>>Marina: I do. I've had, I have help from
some really wonderful animators on this, but
I draw and determine all the key frames and
then people have done some of the rotoscoping
with me. Sorry, I can't answer that in a more
coherent way.
>>presenter: Are there any more questions?
I have a question. You had several pieces
that actually had a whole lot of screens.
This is, it looks like one screen.
>>Marina: Yeah.
>>presenter: But you had some that had, like
20 screens or something like that?
>>Marina: I've done as much as for 21 screens,
yeah.
>>presenter: So, how do you, how do you keep
it [inaudible]?
>>Marina: Well, there's a piece for 21 screens
is in the San Jose Convention Center and it's
on a Cisco system. It's on Cisco's sort of
scheduling system. So, the piece is a site-specific
piece where you're looking at the space that
you're standing in but the space is flooded.
So, it's a very sort of, and it's on a closed
circuit system, so most of the people who
went to see the piece kept asking me if it
was live. Just because closed circuit is such
a dominant paradigm for people to think this
is real or true or live. But that was quite
simple. With the four screen piece, the poster
children, the polar bear piece, which I didn't
show tonight, but all that stuff's on my website.
Its two computers that are checking each other
[ ]. They're just checking to see if they,
to see that they remain in sync. So, it gets
more complicated the more screens you have.
Now there are systems like Akman makes an
M-player system that has a board that'll synchronize
at least six monitors to stay in sync with
each other. So, I like Akman, it's MA and
PA M-players make really great company. Thank
you.
[applause]